okay so recently things with internet
sensation and cultural critic Dave Rubin
have sort of exploded he said that I've
lied about him multiple times at a
recent appearance at the University of
Delaware I'm getting a ton of email
saying David appear on Dave Reubens show
which of course I'm glad to do if he'll
have me that's up to him not up to me or
David invite Dave Rubin on your show
which I don't think he's interested in
doing right now but I did have a
wide-ranging nearly hour-long interview
with him on the program
not that long ago but but before we
stopped talking
effectively and a lot of you haven't
seen that interview so in light of all
of the recent controversy let's check
out dave rubin and i engaging in the
battle of ideas in what i thought was a
very respectable way a couple of years
ago although unfortunately after this we
have barely spoken a word to each other
take a look you be the judge as to what
you think went on here welcome to the
show we're trying something a little bit
different today i'm going to be joined
today for the hour by dave rubin host of
the political talk show the rubin report
on youtube our sort of daily political
wrap-up and stories will be on today's
bonus show so extra incentive to sign up
for that bonus show so dave it's been i
think maybe about a year or more since
we last had you on and when i when i
announced we were gonna be having you on
we received close to 500 different
questions and and concerns and maybe
about 50 insults which is about the
right ratio that i find for you and
we're gonna dig into a bunch of this
stuff but to sort of set this up i got a
tweet from someone the other day
unrelated to this interview who said i
like a diverse media diet
I watched the David Pakman show on the
left and I watched the Reuben report on
the right which was sort of surprising
to me it what's your assessment now of
where your politics are do you consider
yourself to be on the right so to speak
yeah well you've given me a lot there to
start so I'll do the best I can here
back man yeah
of the 500 questions to only 50 haters
or insults that that's an extremely for
the Internet in 2017 that's a
phenomenally good ratio so I want to be
clear about that first as far as that
now I'll dress it in a broad sense first
and then I'll get to your exact question
in the broad sense the person that
commented on that that's a beautiful
thing and that's exactly what we need
more of regardless of left-right or
anything else or what you think about my
politics or your politics we need more
people that are willing to listen to
people from across the spectrum and in
in ways that you wouldn't have listened
to people years ago meaning do it
through podcasts or YouTube or however
else you do it now and all those things
what we need more than ever in this
country I believe is a multitude of
voices who are trying to get across
ideas so that we can have the battle of
ideas so we can figure out what the best
way to move forward is now as to the
specific question of okay I listen to
pac-man I left Rubin on the right I mean
I have said consistently we we
relaunched this show you know I was at
the Young Turks for a while as you were
an affiliate with them as well at the
time we relaunched the show where it
became an interview show basically two
years ago it was September 9th 2015 so
I'm sure at about a month and that's
when I had Sam Harrison on that first
episode and we did a one-on-one
interview and the second I was done with
that interview I thought wow this is
what I want to do you know before that I
was doing sort of a news panel thing and
I'd have three guests usually comedians
a little more like hot topics on the
view or something but I did that show
with Sam and I thought wow we bit into
something important and relevant and
real and honest and I and I loved
interviewing people and I had done it
before a little bit I had a show on
Sirius XM and some other stuff but
that's really where I shifted that's
where I started talking about these
ideas of liberalism and the phrase
classical liberalism which I'm proud to
say is now out there in the in the ether
yeah and you hear this being spoken
about more I mean nobody was talking
about that and I still have all sorts of
problems with people usually on the
right by the way who still associate
everybody else a liberals this liberals
this when they really mean they either
mean progressives
or they mean people of the
which sort of gets to the heart of your
question so first off I don't think the
left right thing really has much bearing
anymore I've said this many times but I
think the Trump elect you know the
election and then the Trump presidency
has tossed the chessboard up I had
Andrew Clavin on here a couple weeks ago
he said it rammed a truck through
everything whatever metaphor you want to
use for it it has created a situation
where everybody is real you ating
whatever it is that they believe and why
they believe it so when you just say the
typical ideas of the left or of the
right to me it's really more about
libertarian versus authoritarian I don't
mean libertarian in the political party
I mean the sense of individual liberty
versus sort of state authority
technically look technically if we were
to get all the definitions in the
old-school way of looking at them a
classical liberalism which is pretty
close to lib to libertarianism
technically is thought of as on the
right side of the spectrum so I don't
again I think these things are kind of
archaic ways of talking about things but
you know we all get caught in labels I
say it all the time you know I have to
use labels at some level to get ideas
across and then at the same time as
labels change they become less useful
which by the way it's one of the reasons
that I don't say regressive left as much
as I used to because I think we made a
point with it and people started
understanding what we were talking about
because for a long time people were sort
of thinking a lot of the things that
that you and I have discussed they were
thinking these things they needed a
label to sort of grasp what we were
talking about now I think people
understand it so I've shifted away now
some people use it more that so be it
but anyway if you want to get down to
the technical side of it I would say
that that true liberalism classical
liberalism which is about the individual
and live-and-let-live and and logic and
reason I would say that that's firmly
truly in the center because what you're
really trying to do is is bring in the
fringes because you realize that most of
us are in somewhere in the center yeah I
mean I think that well so there's a lot
there I mean to sort of get to whether
your politics have changed because
that's one of the big questions has so
aside from where however you label your
place
the spectrum there are many who believe
your politics have decidedly changed
when you used to be arguably sort of
under the progressive umbrella but you
differed with some of your colleagues on
issues of free speech and censorship and
the israeli-palestinian conflict -
really now under the label of classical
liberalism supporting more genuinely
right-wing ideas before we dig into any
specific policy do you believe that your
views have actually changed or are you
labeling your views in a different way
no my views haven't changed I've said
this a couple of times if anything I
would say on some economic stuff I've
shifted a little bit more libertarian so
I'm on taxes for example or on some
regulation stuff which I'm happy to
discuss if you want but in terms of
everything else in terms of gay marriage
I'm married to a dude he's in the other
room that's pretty for gay marriage I'm
for legalizing marijuana I'm for
euthanasia for reforming the prison
system I'm pro-choice I'm basically for
single-payer health care these are all
things that are thought of as either
progressive or laughter liberal or
whatever so yeah I've shifted a little
bit on some of the economic stuff
because by the way for the last two
years I've sat across some brilliant
thinkers and public intellectuals and
professors mostly people that have
argued in front of the Supreme Court
I mean experts in their field who have
shifted some of my views a little bit
right in terms of economics but in terms
of everything else I believe those same
things by the way I will say this that
when I was on The Young Turks I always
considered myself liberal I don't think
you'll ever find a moment where I flat
out said I was a progressive I was
around a lot of progressives and at the
time I thought a lot of what they said
made sense but then as I sort of had my
awakening I you know one of the things
that I think a lot of your audience will
be familiar with this and maybe you are
to a degree as well is that when you
start seeing the the corrosive effect of
a lot of this stuff that's happening on
the Left right now it starts under it
undermines almost all of the rest of it
at once but and once you see it you
can't stop it's like a wave and then you
go wait a minute this one little thing I
think a little differently on this and
then suddenly you see why it affects so
many other issues let's put let's pause
on that part because
you want to dig in more into detail on
that in a subsequent part of the
interview but it to get to the politics
of it the policies you described a lot
of them they they're sort of at odds
with classical liberalism I mean want to
give you one example and I'm wondering
maybe if the classical liberalism term
is being used a little too loosely right
now by some and we're doing a long form
deep dive into classical liberalism
that'll be out in a couple of weeks I
mean one example would be a sort of
foundational classical liberalism tenet
is the government should be involved not
at all in anything that the free market
can provide now it's not can provide
efficiently or can provide pretty well
but can provide so according to
classical liberalism health care is
something that should be 100 percent in
the free market and that means no
pre-existing conditions or it costs 10
times as much if you have pre-existing
conditions or whatever it is that
for-profit corporations want to do the
view you stated yourself having on
single-payer health care it could not be
more opposed to classical liberalism so
is it possible it's maybe not the right
label for you know it's not possible
because I know all the classical
liberalism quite well and I and I assure
you it's not look I've had many people
on I would recommend your your audience
check out some of my interviews with
Steve Davies with Randy Barnett with
Deidre McCloskey these are these are
professors at what very well-known
schools who've explained a lot of this
stuff Brandon Davies from Clemson a
bunch of other people that's sorry
Brandon Turner basically I think for
this look we can we can whittle down
every definition to everybody this is
exactly how you have to think if you're
this or that I mean we could we could
sit here and go well you know you're
only a Democrat if you exactly believe
this or exactly believe that nobody
demonstrate I think that's up to be
clear Democrat is a political party
affiliation and I think that's very
different than an ideology like
classical liberalism which has some
pretty well defined characteristics sure
so for most of the guests that I've had
on here who I
and if I as as classical liberals I
would venture to say almost everybody
actually the easiest way I can explain
it is that if you are a pure libertarian
and and this is hard to pin down because
libertarians are sort of all over the
place you have the wing of libertarians
that don't want driver's licenses and
then you have libertarians think are a
little more realistic and then and then
by the way you have an Capps who want
absolutely no government and all that
stuff
classical liberals generally I think
believe that the principles of the
individual and of liberty and your right
to do things for yourself and
free-market principles by the way are
the best way to go about doing things
but there's a realism there related to
the state which is that it exists it has
to provide certain things especially in
a country like America where we have 300
or 350 million people whatever it is and
there there has to be some balance so
I've seen many times and this would be
the the view that I look that a
classical liberal position generally it
sort of it sort of takes the libertarian
principle and then adds some element of
realistic government involvement so you
know we can whittle down to those words
mean absolute necessity or whatever it
is but I think the general accepted term
is that there's some government
involvement but you want to always err
on the side of individual freedom which
I absolutely do on the issue of the
single-payer health care though because
I think this is a good lens specifically
because of your views on this do you
agree that single-payer would not be the
libertarian perspective with a slight
tweak to make it the classically liberal
perspective it is diametrically opposed
to what a classical liberal would want
yeah you know it's funny I I get invited
to a lot of college things and I'm
always invited by the way by by
conservatives or libertarians usually or
people of the right which is funny to me
because you'd think it shows that
they're certainly willing to talk to
people who are pro-choice and pro
and I get no invites from anyone left so
I was doing a speech for the students
for Liberty in DC a couple maybe two
months ago and I'm talking about all
these things that I'm poor and I said
sorry about single-payer health
and they booed me but then everyone
started laughing after because it was
very obvious that the whole purpose of
me brink coming there was that we don't
have to agree on everything and then we
all had a good laugh about it I thought
what a great moment that is that we can
all go you know what we still want to
live in the same country anyway as far
as single-payer health care this isn't I
haven't done a tremendous amount on
health care on the show and I should do
more actually why maybe we'll save that
for later because I noticed that that
you don't talk about that and it's
potentially affecting you know tens of
millions of people tomorrow you know
what I mean I was surprised that you
weren't talking as much about it
I think it's sort of ancillary bounced
in and out of the specific you know I
what I try to do on the show is I like
talking about the principles and the
ideas mostly and I try not to get caught
in the sort of day-to-day the news part
of it and especially because of the way
people consume news now it's like
everything changes so quickly in the
24-hour news cycle changes so quickly
that I don't want to always be doing the
catch up on that but but whatever that's
fine I would say that to me the best
idea for health care as I see it would
be that basically you would have the the
private companies would be in control
because they have to decide what they
have to make money they have to have a
functioning business I do believe that's
a realistic thing at the same time there
is a piece of do you want people to be
able to get health insurance that have
pre-existing conditions absolutely do
you want to do things that aren't always
about the bottom line now this is where
a libertarian might say okay well it's
tough for that person and they have to
go to their local church or their
whatever their community and help them
now I believe the state does have some
responsibility there I think this is a
classical liberal position so so I would
say the best the most realistic way that
I think you could do this basically
would be that you would have private
companies that would sort of all be
facilitated and exchanged with some
facilitating by the government were like
isn't that Obamacare basically said
we're still keeping health insurance as
a for-profit endeavor but in order to
participate you have to abide by certain
striction x' and we will also sort of
regulate some portion of these plans
through an exchange that I'm hearing
exactly what the Affordable Care Act is
yeah well first off you can go back to
my tweets and many videos that I did I
was not against Obamacare yeah
knowing that is a criticism and it's
just sounding like what the Affordable
Care Act I wasn't against Obamacare I
was frustrated with a lot of how they
did it you know I'm not someone that
believes that the ends justify the means
and if you remember when Obama was
running he was constantly talking about
how transparent we're gonna be and we're
gonna air this stuff on c-span and
everyone will know and we know is all
backdoor deals and congressmen that were
suddenly retiring out of nowhere after
they sign things and all kinds of shady
stuff but that's just government
nonsense which is another reason why I'm
for small government as a general rule I
think that there is some overreach by
the government on I have a some issue
with the government forcing people to
buy something there's something there
but I could put I can basically get over
that look I can tell you this I have a
very good friend who for the last 10 10
or 15 years has been a very successful
doctor I don't want to say what state
he's in but a very successful doctor
Obamacare came in and his practice in
many ways has been wrecked because he
stuck with all these regulations and
doing more paperwork than seeing people
and all this other stuff now I know
that's just an antic total thing but you
do hear a lot of these stories so the
basic premise though of what you're
saying having some exchange that the
government says you have to sort of hit
these certain marks I just don't know
that it's exactly been rolled out
properly I think there's a lot of
evidence that it hasn't but again I mean
look at the day Obamacare was passed I
tweeted something that got something
like 50 it was fifty thousand retweets
which at the time I think was one of the
top ten most read it retweeted things
ever so but so Dave I'm trying to I just
want to I just so we can drill down so
you're you're agreeing that what you
described as your ideal scenario sounds
like Obamacare but your problem with
Obamacare isn't how it was written but
rather that the implementation wasn't
exactly as it was designed well no there
are first of all first off I'm not a
health care expert I mean I know
everyone wants to pretend they're
experts
everything I don't it seems to me that
there are probably unnecessary
regulations or expectations out of some
of the insurance companies and and the
doctors frankly I'm working I'm less
concerned about a giant corporation
that's an insurance company mm-hmm that
we know these companies make tons and
tons of money I'm much more concerned
about the ability for the doctor and the
patient to have the best relationship
possible the doctor to make the right
choices which I've heard a lot of things
from from several doctors that that
there are reasons sometimes that they
can't even make the best choices that
they think to do or sometimes they'll do
a procedure before they think it's
necessary all sorts of other stuff but
the basic premise of what Obamacare is
of the government facilitating the
private exchanges I don't have a I don't
have a problem with it but like most
things private or public but especially
public it could probably be done a
little better fair enough yeah and as
far as you know I think that one of the
big issues is if we had single-payer and
we had also outcome based compensation
rather than you get paid for each thing
that you do which is sort of one of the
key aspects of the system we have you
would eliminate a lot of what we're
seeing doctors doing but let's put a
pause on the healthcare conversation and
in fact we'll take a quick break and
then Dave we will resume with you and we
just have so much else to talk about
we're speaking with Dave Rubin host of
the Rubin report and we'll be back after
this we're continuing our conversation
with Dave Rubin who is of course host of
the political talk showed the Rubin
report on YouTube growing by the day I
think is fair to say so Dave let let's
now turn to we've sort of talked a
little bit about your political views
generally and I want to get a little bit
to some of the most popular questions as
I mentioned nearly 500 questions and
about 50 insults that came in related to
this interview some of the insults
directed at you some of the insults
directed at me lots of anti-semitism to
go around no shortage of that ever but
there are a couple things that kept
coming up okay one is and I know you've
heard about this the criticism of your
interviewing style and as it as it
generally goes the criticism is there
are people who go on the Rubin report
they say things that are demonstrably on
true oriT or at minimum highly deceptive
and dave rubin doesn't challenge them so
let me just sort of give you the
opportunity to explain what your
approach is and why what underlies what
some might perceive as not challenging
guests when when maybe they deserve to
be challenged yeah well first can you
give me an example of that
sure so like for example when you had
david horowitz on and he said obama's a
communist and he did include it in a
sentence where he said a lot of things
that were untrue you could have I guess
conceivably picked out any of those
things but it was just sort of allowed
to slide where if if you had a different
style you might have said can you tell
me what Obama has done that makes him a
communist in his legislation or whatever
the case may be I guess that's one
example okay so I don't so first off
David Horowitz saying that Obama's
economist that's his opinion of what he
thinks about Obama I don't know that
it's actually the debunk Apple though
right you could say well if someone is a
communist there must be something you
can attribute to them that would be
communistic well I think lawyer or
arbiter here but I think he would argue
that the policies that Obama put in
place like Obama care whether you agree
or not or other thing or large taxes and
things like that that he would view
those as as communist ideals let's say
but anyway putting that aside yeah my my
interview style by the way you know it's
funny to take questions I don't take
question as an interviewer I don't take
questions from my audience because I
always feel that it's it's better if
these things come from my head and also
there's an odd self selection so if you
tweet out you know I'm taking questions
for Dave or whatever you know mostly
what you're gonna get is the haters
because those are the people that know I
know Dave but I mean you know me well
enough to know that I mean the questions
that I did not even pay attention to or
the ones that I really think we wouldn't
get anything out of like as an
individual I believe I'm curious because
your style is so much different from
mine
your style might be better I mean
there's no rule that your my style is
better I'm curious what your approach is
in terms of style yeah and believe me
I'm not I'm not accusing you of anything
I just think there's a there's an
interesting we always forget about this
selection which is important because in
a day in a day of social media you only
hear from the screaming people of God I
even see this I even see this when I get
emails you know I get tons of email
every day people saying really nice
things I get people you know I get
Muslims in Saudi Arabia and Christian
conservatives in Missouri and saying to
almost the same exact things to me and
then you know but the ones that stick
out in my head are the ones where people
are just telling me to go you know eff
myself or badly okay put that aside my
interview style I've said this many
times is I believe that the best way to
interview somebody is to really be able
to hear what they think and the way you
do that is you listen now when David
Horowitz in this specific instance when
he said that communist thing I was in
that particular case I was about to stop
him but you're right he then did quickly
he like sort of said it it was right at
the top of the interview he kind of flew
right into something else and then and
then the conversation just went from
there I do remember thinking the
interview that I wanted to get back to
it but in the course of an hour
conversation I think that one was almost
an hour and 20 minutes you know
sometimes something's gonna get lost my
belief is that if you let people speak
you can either figure out if they know
what they're talking about or not I
think one of the problems that we have
right now in mainstream media and you
know 10 guests in little boxes screaming
at each other and all this one of the
things that it's done is that it's made
it so that everyone talks in sound bites
I've done some of these cable news shows
I think you have even when I do those if
you know you only have five minutes you
gotta say things real quick and also if
you want to get booked again through I
sort of say it in a passion way and
bah-bah-bah and over-the-top and all
this stuff this is terrible for public
discourse it's terrible for the
extrapolation of ideas and it's terrible
for for a real dialogue that we should
be having so my belief is that if I sit
across from somebody and I really listen
to them and and listen to them say what
they think then I try to ask the right
questions to figure out why they think
that but
my goal is not unless I'm having
something that's closer to a debate
which you know two or three weeks ago I
had Michael Shermer who's skeptic and
dennis prager who's a believer in
morality and god it was it's what i
believe it to be more of a conversation
than a debate because I think that's
just a more helpful way to view it but
my view is let these people talk and you
can tell you can tell because I don't
think my audience is stupid I think my
audience is really bright as I suspect
yours is as well when someone doesn't
know what they're talking about or when
they blatantly lie they will hang
themselves you will you can see it they
will wrap the rope around their neck and
they will hang themselves so I try to
ask the right questions to get the most
out of them yeah I mean I think this may
be it's just a difference in approach
right but like I would imagine maybe
you're right that David Horowitz thinks
Obama's a communist because of Obamacare
and taxes but then I would say it might
this is my instinct you know I would say
well what taxes are you talking about
and then it would be like oh he's a
communist because he allowed the top
income tax rate to go from 36 to 39
percent I mean it's like it so my
interest would be in if there's an
assertion made that is a what I you know
I didn't know the president was a
communist that's interesting how do you
define that I feel like we would get a
lot out of that you know and it's not
it's just the difference in approach I
think is what we chalk it up to that's
listen I always say to people people say
well I don't like the way you do this
really that I'm like well someone
forcing you to watch this thing if
you've got someone that you like better
than me watch that or if you think
somebody's a better interview or that
best I do this is just what I'm doing I
like it people happen to like what I'm
doing which is great but yes you know by
the way in that interview I was really I
thought we were gonna spend almost you
know he David Horowitz was a hardcore
lefty child of Communists who was a
lefty Berkeley guy in the 60s who then
evolved and now he's thought of as hard
right I think he's probably he's
probably he's pretty hard right maybe
not diamond but whatever is the next
softest stone he's right no doubt about
it but my purpose of that interview he's
written many books of you know I had
Siddalee done that video only a few
months before on Praeger about why i
left the left and why I don't think
liberalism has anything to do with the
left and print and Horowitz had sort of
been through that experience many many
years before has written many books
about it wrote an article about it
during Reagan's reelection so I really
wanted to focus on that so occasional
look occasionally something's gonna get
by it's just how it is and by the way
you know my my friend and and who I'm
thrilled to call a friend an honor to
call friend and mentor Larry King you
know a lot of people used to say that
when Larry you know he's still doing
interviews now and I and I love him and
I just saw him last week yeah but you
when he when he was in his heyday let's
say in the 80s and 90s on on CNN a lot
of people said well he doesn't attack
the people the right way he doesn't
follow up the right way blah blah blah I
I think my follow-ups are actually
pretty good and I think as I said
bye-bye
subtly talking to people you can get
them to explain themselves sometimes
into a corner if they don't know what
they're talking about but you know
everyone's gonna have their critics and
I'm actually completely okay with that
and by the way maybe in five years from
now I'll look back and go oh I should
have done that a little different or you
know I you know everyone involves and
figures things out I think this the
quick rush to judgment I think is kind
of unfortunate but it's alright hey I've
got no shortage of interviews I look
back at and say what on earth was I
thinking that day but unfortunately I
can't redo those a lot of those people
don't talk to me anymore sadly no I'm
kind of kidding but no the certain
certainly looking back and wishing I had
done things differently I think is a
common thing we're talking with Dave
Rubin host of the political talk show
the Rubin report on YouTube more after
the break let's pick up our conversation
with Dave Rubin host of the political
talk show the Rubin report on YouTube so
I thought it would be interesting Dave
to talk a little bit about because
you're increasingly not doing this on
your show deliberately as you talked
about in order to stay away from the
sort of 24-hour news cycle generally
speaking were six month in months into
the Trump administration how do you
assess this presidency so far you know I
think it's unfortunately it's become so
polarizing even talking about Trump that
making an assessment that's a clear
honest assessment no matter how you do
it you're gonna you're gonna get some
hysterical stuff but
I'll do the best thing yeah so first off
just to be clear I did not vote for
Trump I voted for Gary Johnson and I
should be judged accordingly I did
videos on how to stop Trump
I talked to people that I admire at the
highest level such as Sam Harris on why
you shouldn't vote for Trump and what
his fears were from the week before the
election I had Hillary Rosen on who is a
progressive pundit and does tons of work
with the DNC about why she hated Trump
then I had plenty of Trump not plenty of
Trump people but I had a couple Trump
people on including Scott Adams who I
think was the best public advocate for
if you wanted to vote for Trump why to
vote anyway I did not vote for him my
feeling was after after the election my
feeling was that be the fact that the
chessboard as I described before has
been thrown up and everyone's resale you
ating things versus that if Hillary had
been elected the screws that had about
all the stuff that we talked about about
mainstream media and the corrupt
politicians and all this stuff those
screws would have been tightened it
would have been really bad for
independent media people it would have
been bad for just the slow degradation
of society that we're seeing and
discourse with all the screws would have
been tightened against us so Trump
although I did not support him by
throwing this chess board up or driving
the truck through it or whatever you
want to use to describe it I think that
has created a net good in that right now
there are more people talking about
politics reevaluating what they think
getting engaged whether for him or
against him then I've certainly seen in
my lifetime
okay so let's pause there briefly
because you just now work you've just
said a lot I think you're about to get
to the parts where we're going to
disagree but so far you've said
something I've been saying for a while
which is if Hillary Clinton had won we
would have seen significantly lower
engagement in politics you would have
seen many on the Left sort of say hey
we've got a Democrat in the White House
so we can sort of tune out for four
years which would have led to a disaster
in the 2018 midterms and the reality is
that as as someone who was a center to
center right in Hillary Clinton which I
believe her to be I think it actually
would have not been particularly good
for
the left which I consider myself to be a
part on so so far I agree with you the
Trump presidency and the what I see as
the endless scandals have really
reinvigorated activism in an in an
interesting way
not exactly what you said but I'm sort
of agreeing with you here yes and I
think that that's all legit and also you
know that fits within the things that I
care about the things that I care about
are talking about the ideas talking
about the principles again not
necessarily every day-to-day decision or
monitoring his Twitter so that I can
start getting outraged because now
there's you know there's media companies
that literally spend all day waiting for
him to tweet so they can write about how
outraged everyone is so they're doing
pre outrage before people even have a
chance for every day now as far as the
actual presidency I guess we should
spend a minute on on Russia first just
because that's what everybody seems to
go to now look it seems to me that they
haven't been able to pin anything
directly you know a month ago it was all
the Comey stuff that didn't seem to work
out two weeks ago is all the Trump jr.
stuff that didn't seem to work out this
week I guess there's some anaphoric
stuff we'll see if that works out if if
we were to go on the assumption for a
second I'll do it both ways for you if
we're going on the assumption that Trump
did somehow collude with Russia then
what you're saying is that technically
we should be at war with Russia right
now that you'd have to then depose Trump
and of course pence and then I guess you
then install the Speaker of the House
Paul Ryan now in a lot of ways by doing
that you'd have a worse person for the
Democrats because Paul Ryan by most
estimations especially economically is
certainly to the right of Trump and
maybe on some social stuff yeah but Dave
let me I I don't want to I don't want to
interrupt you but only because we've
done the rush of stuff up and down I'm
more curious like for example on the
stuff Trump has actually done like not
whether he colluded with Russia but what
is there like a particular policy or
something Trump has done that you think
is really good and or what has he done
that you think is is really a disaster
if there's anything like what do you see
as the highs and lows of the six months
yeah just give me 30 seconds on the
Russia thing I'll wrap that up though
because my point is that if you're
saying that there was collusion or they
knew about us we are in effect at war I
mean could there possibly be a bigger
act of war than installing a president
so what you're saying is that if it
would
be president Ryan or we'd have to redo
an election and get Hillary I mean the
first thing we would have to do is go to
war with Russia I do not want to go to
war with Russia I don't think there's
any reason to go to work Russia but
hypothetically did would you say going
to war with Russia is so bad that we
should allow an illegitimate president
if it were determined to be such yeah oh
I I believe in evidence and logic and
reason so if one day if tomorrow
literally the second I hang up with you
right now if I go on Twitter and they
say well we figured it out we actually
got the tail
it's figured out Trump was installed or
the Russian government actually colluded
and then we had to go ahead and do that
well then of course I don't want a
Russian puppet but all I'm saying is you
need evidence yeah and I think we have a
lot more theory er than evidence okay so
that's one thing well that's your other
question the specifics of the policies
look when george w bush was president
I was against executive actions when
when Obama was president I was against
executive actions when Trump who's now
used a ton of them I've been against
them we have three branches of
government we can do a little Poli Sci
101 the legislative branch is supposed
to write the laws the executive branch
signs them into law that's the president
and then of course the Supreme Court or
the court systems figure out if these
laws are legal the idea that we're doing
so much through the executive branch I
think is horrific
for for democracy and for the rule of
law and for how this country is supposed
to operate so the fact that he is so
willing to do that and by the way it
shows you the limitations of this
silliness so when Obama did all this
stuff with electronic pen or whatever he
did well guess what it all because it
didn't go through the legislative
process it all got reversed by Trump
with the sign of that same pen so I
think the the deferment of power which
by the way is there's everyone's
culpable in this we the people are but
Congress which doesn't pass laws anymore
and doesn't have real debates and really
figure out what they're trying to do
they're they're very good at
investigating themselves and
investigating other branches of
government but they don't seem to be
able to pass laws and function the way
that they're supposed to and be the
representatives of the people that
they're supposed to be so that my main
issue with him is that obviously you
Trump is a wild card in that I don't
know what the Trump
political ethos is other than its it's
for Trump I get you know there's this
make America great again or you know
drain the swamp or all those things but
that to me is not a political ethos I
care about ideas I care I want someone
to come in and say these are the these
are the principles that I believe in and
this is how I'm going to try to govern
and I simply don't know what that is I
don't know what Trump's moral center is
if there was a real crisis you know if
there was a horrible terrorist attack or
if there was a Missile Crisis with North
Korea or something he's trumped the the
level-headed person you want dealing
with this now you could probably and his
people would make an argument that he's
put in people like mattis that that
would do these things well and and he
would defer to them okay that that's
possible but my biggest issue with him
is that I just don't know what his
political beliefs truly are other than
sort of the day-to-day machinations of
playing the media and playing that fight
and I don't think that that's great for
democracy but has he not done anything
like his tax policy proposal or what it
is that he seemingly wants although who
really knows it seems like he doesn't
even now it seems he confused health
insurance with life insurance this
entire time but what he claims to want
to do about health insurance or whatever
is there any policy idea that he's put
forth that you say that's what I
disagree with the most it's a disaster
well the tax stuff I don't particularly
disagree with I this is as I restarted
the interview I said I've shifted a
little right on taxes I believe you have
the right to keep as much as you earn as
much as you can as you are now I do
believe we need to pay into the system
to have roads and social services and
things like that which by the way there
are some libertarians who don't so I
think this is something that you could
couch in that classical liberal Avenue
but but lowering taxes as a general rule
I'm completely for even if it's in a way
even if it's in a way that would be bad
for the economy I well you'd have to you
know I guess what I mean yeah that's
sort of vague I mean what I mean is
there we have nothing we can point to
that suggests sort of supply-side
stimulus by tax cuts for the very rich
is good for the economy we have periods
where it's been done and it hasn't been
acutely bad but there's no period
there's there's no evidence that it's
good so for me I would say okay there's
the question of what's ethical or moral
and there's also the question of the
economic impact of it that's sort of my
background so I would say it's hard for
me to support something that would be
economically damaging well I don't know
that there's any direct evidence that
it's economically damaging but also we
would have to widdle through and we
could do this in a week or so if you
want
we'd have to widdle through exactly what
the tax plan said but again as a general
rule I want you David Pakman as a small
business owner which you are with
employees to pay the least amount of
taxes that you can so that you can hire
more people so that you can build a
better studio so that you can invest
more in your operation and bring the
goodness that is you and your operation
out there I know this as a small
businessman now if I had been being
taxed higher right now I amassed capital
costs to build this studio and do all
this stuff I by the way I pay a hundred
percent of my employees health insurance
a hundred percent I also give my
director gets a gets a cut of our
YouTube Rev I do all the things I try to
put my beliefs into practice but that's
a confusion for me Dave because if those
capital expenses are tax deductible so
if the tax rate goes up for you as an
individual if you've got pass-through
income or for for the business tax rate
it doesn't matter what the business tax
rate if is if you want to spend money on
capital because that you don't pay taxes
on that actually it encourages you to
spend money on capital to have a higher
tax rate so I under I understand what
that argument is and I would argue at
the same time as that yeah that having
every one of us every one of us whether
you whether you whatever however much
you earn it is your money it is your
money we get taxed in all kinds of other
ways with sales tax and everything else
I pay payroll tax and blah blah blah and
I would say the best way to if you right
now if you're on the left or you're a
progressive and you hate Trump and you
hate what this gun has become I don't
think that the best answer is to topple
the government and destroy this
incredible experiment which is what it
is this American
Behrman I don't think the best way is to
destroy I think the best way is to rein
in the power that it has over us and one
of the ways you can do that is by giving
it less money I think that the
government could function a lot slimmer
and trimmer I think most people I think
actually you could probably get most
progressives to admit that that
government is a giant waste but often
they'll tell you how much they hate the
government and then the solution is more
or more taxes I would say the only way
to really control this stuff is to is to
tighten the strings on on the finances
and you have the right to or keep as
much as possible of what you are fair
enough and that's more more of an
ethical argument than an economic one I
think you would agree I would have to
look at the eye
I suppose in this case I'm making the
ethical argument which I think if things
were more done on the grounds of ethics
yeah then sort of staring at numbers and
projecting things and the CBO which
projects things for twenty years and
it's always wrong about everything or
all the pundits who project things are
always wrong and all the polls that are
always wrong I think doing some things
based on ethical principles might
actually have some more long-term
positive benefits to society all right
let's pause there we'll be back for our
few remaining moments with Dave Rubin
host of the political show the Rubin
report on YouTube back after this
sticking with us is Dave Rubin host of
the political talk show the Rubin report
on YouTube we've talked Trump we've
talked classical liberalism we've talked
about so many different things
okay so Dave I sat through what felt
like a very enjoyable endless hours of
Rubin report and there's a couple very
specific things I want to touch on
because I feel like they might be
attacks on me personally not not
directly but de-facto you said in an
enemy who you said innocent in an
interview with ben shapiro that
liberalism is basically a mental
disorder what did you mean by that I
don't think I said liberalism I might
have said progressivism or maybe you
said the left is basically a mental
disorder that I think the idea was
recive ISM left-left ISM whatever the
case may be is basically a mental
disorder for the record if I said
liberalism then it was an absolute brain
freeze it but I'm 99% sure I didn't say
that it may have been before if they
have been before you started but before
you shifted language on it it was a
little bit a little bit ago yeah I don't
think so though but anyway I'm sure that
some of the internet salutes around here
will find it I'm pretty sure I said
progressivism okay um well first off it
had nothing to do with you you know no I
know it's to be personally but I am
curious like what about progressive
ideology strikes you as being a mental
disorder okay so first off I said it in
in a glib way do I think it's an actual
mental disorder no I don't think it's a
mental disorder that should be studied I
would like to study a couple of these
progressives but I would study some
conservatives two and one you know you
could probably figure out that their
brains are wired a little differently
okay fine
so putting that aside the the big I was
being glib obviously but the point that
I'm trying to make is that the I sort of
what I just said to you in the previous
segment if your issues are the gut you
know think about all the proof I mean
while I was on TYT for years
everything's about the government's
horrible everyone's corrupt everyone's
evil corporations money is destroying
everything billionaires buh-buh-bah
what's your answer make the government
bigger tax people more force the
government to do more below that seems
antithetical to logic and reason so I
saw yes it is not a mental disorder but
I think basically if you could get a
group of progressives to sit down and
not scream at you that you're a bigot
and a racist and a homophobe which by
the way I'm sure that there are people
that flirt use those slurs on you even
though you are of the left and consider
yourself a progressive I think if you
could get some people to sit down and
really talk about ideas and these
principles and the philosophic
underpinnings of the things that we're
talking about I think you could get
people to understand that if your
problem is the corruption your the
problem is the money and all those
things then stop making the problem
bigger that this isn't about what the
founding fathers intended they intended
a very weak federal government and local
control and local power and state power
and I'm for all of the
thing so yes this the comment was done
glibly but I assure you it had nothing
to do with the attack well I think that
this is where you know we sort of get to
what I think is my my core disagreement
with you aside from like really specific
policy things like it seems like we're
sort of in a different place on Tax
Policy for example we probably don't
agree exactly on what the size of the
government should be but you and I have
talked privately about our concerns with
the sort of speech policing trigger
warning safe space stuff we've both
talked about that we've expressed
concern about some knee-jerk positions
that don't seem fact based on the
israeli-palestinian conflict etc I think
it's a matter of degree that I think you
believe that those issues are much
bigger among the left than I perceive
them to be
and I've talked about the college campus
stuff that's going on but I still think
it's limited to a particular type of
mostly you know liberal arts colleges I
don't think it's the major issues that
some of your guests make it out to be
are we sort of having a disagreement too
on the degree to which these issues are
a problem yeah so I would say that's a
fair place that we disagree which by the
way I love having a disagreement pac-man
you know I like you I consider you a
friend you you we're gonna do my show if
you were gonna be in LA last week it
didn't work but we'll get in here the
whole point of this this experiment as I
described it before of America is that
we're supposed to disagree on these
things we're supposed to disagree and be
able to walk away and realize that we
want to live in the same society because
I don't want to kill you for your
beliefs and hopefully you don't want to
kill me for mine so as for the the free
speech stuff no I I don't think that I'm
overstating it or that my guests are
overstating it this this idea of the
trigger warnings of the safe spaces of
the speech police of deep platforming
Richard Dawkins at Berkeley which is
happening on August 7 he's been deep
platform I'm at the I'm actually
interviewing him in New York at the 92nd
Street Y on August 8th they haven't
stopped us yet but I'm sure there will
be people that aren't happy that we're
doing that this kind of insanity
stopping Jordan Peterson from speaking
being I'm sure I don't have to tell you
about what happened with brett weinstein
up at evergreen state so
everything's a great example by the way
because this is supposed to be the most
left that you could argue that this is
the most left college in America well
certainly in the top 10 so you would
think that they would have all this
harmony that these ideas of non racism
and plurality and all of this stuff in
multiculturalism would have worked but
the students there would have you
believed that this is some sort of
insane racist crazy place Brett
Weinstein was fighting racism he was
fighting segregation no I get that and I
defended him I mean I got a call about
it a couple weeks ago and I defended him
and you know a lot of my family is is
college professors and I've got an
announcement to make about a college
involvement that I'm gonna be having and
from my from from everything I'm looking
at there are these several dozen
examples that you cite but the idea that
the left at large has been taken over by
this it's like I went to the women's
March rallies here in Boston and there
was about 10% stuff that I thought was
totally unproductive and a shutdown of
attempts for open debate and it was bad
and I'm against it but I'm just not on
board that it's a problem to the degree
that you think it is and I think it's
really easy to look at these isolated
incidents and believe that it represents
everybody on the left but I'm just not
seeing it well first off I've never said
it represents everybody unless it
represents what the mainstream Left has
become without question now we can just
disagree on the percentage there and
that's fine but these look we know that
by they've done a zillion Studies on it
I don't I don't want to quote the number
wrong but that's something like 80 or 90
percent of professors in America are
liberal to left now it depends what you
mean by liberal of course in that case
but we know that the conservative
viewpoint is not being taught in in
colleges and by the way it's leaking
into not just the humanities it's
actually leaking into the science stuff
and I was at a conference with about 400
college professors in Dallas a couple
weeks ago and many people were talking
about that so I've talked to tons of
professors about this I would recommend
if you can get Jonathan Haidt on your
show I think he's doing the best work on
this and run something called a
heterodox Academy which is about getting
more diversity of thought at college
campuses but when I go to college
campuses I get kids from every walk of
life and every color and sexuality and
all that
all that diversity that the left loves I
care about diversity of thought more but
I get kids saying that they their
teachers are telling them to use certain
gender pronouns they say well I'm not
against trans people but if I see
someone who they happen to look like a
man I'm gonna say he or him and I'm not
trying to offend anybody and it's and
they want them to use Z or Zed or
whatever the hell it is that these ideas
these ideas which are taking root in the
left this this strange alliance with
Islam all of this stuff that's taking
root and left is not being countered by
anyone on the left actually
anytime someone on the Left tries to
counter it they're kicked out and and I
think you can probably speak to that
yourself
and certainly thing I mean I get
criticized no there's no doubt I I mean
I'm on the left and I counter it I've
not yet been kicked out of any place
none of my college speaking events that
are planned for the fall have been
canceled so far I mean if it happens
I'll absolutely tell you as well as my
audience you know yeah well I I don't
know what your specific criticisms have
been that they would that would they
would lead you to lead them to kicking
you out yeah but as a general rule as a
general rule there is no question in my
mind that that people that are thought
of as traditionally right at the moment
are being more tolerant of other ideas
than people of the left it's just i I
see this in every walk of life I also
fear that the the biggest problem we
have right now is that the ideas of the
left of a bigger state of taking more of
the collective versus the individual I
would recommend your audience watch my
either in my interviews with ayaan Hirsi
Ali who does a wonderful explanation of
the the individual and why we have to
care about individual rights as opposed
to collective rights yeah um I these
ideas of the left I think are a far
bigger because they've taken such root
with young people I think there are a
far bigger threat to the future of this
pluralistic wonderful society that we
have than anything that I see coming out
of the right at the moment you could
actually make lots arguments that the
right has changed there's virtually no
one on the right that cares about gay
marriage anymore that's a pretty that's
a pretty significant Maci's of people
that write to me day if you should see
them the people that write to me no
listen I mean I think that I think that
that's um
listen what we we've now gotten to the
maybe biggest disagreement that we have
which is I really believe that that the
opposite of what you just said is true
which is that these are relatively sort
of compartmentalized problems on the
left and unfortunately we've reached the
end of our time I think the audience
will not be shocked to hear that we
disagree on that but okay yeah on the
left
besides you it's calling this stuff out
who is calling out this phrased
intersectional lunacy of the Dyke March
and who's calling out Linda Sarsour and
all that you know what they're not
they're actually tweeting more and more
I stand with her Bernie and Van Jones
and all of these people so who is doing
it in an effective way calling out their
worst elements I don't know I don't know
any of those people I'm like I'm in my
silo here in Boston but but think about
that and that's why I'm saying they're
being led by their worst elements
because they because people are afraid
to step up because they'll be called
racist and bigoted and all that others
so that's the part that is that's why I
believe that it is so corrosive and it
is silencing people in in a really
dangerous way Dave Rubin host of the
political talk show the Rubin report I
don't know whether we've solved any
problems during this conversation but
it's been fascinating and I think that
just having it is something that
hopefully my audience will enjoy Dave
thanks for taking close to an hour of
your time to talk to me today
my pleasure pac-man let's do it again